sometimes you can tell if two animals
are related just by looking at them
it's no surprise dogs and wolves share a
common ancestor
or that tree squirrels and chipmunks are
in the same family
but occasionally two different species
share a relation which stretches the
mind
so for this entry into the archive let's
take a look at the animals you'd never
guess
would show up to the same family reunion
to start off
we have rhinos and horses just looking
at the multi-ton
leathery rhino you might sooner guess
it's the cousin of the elephant or
hippopotamus but despite appearances
horses are much closer relatives to
these giants
how is this possible well while the
exact common ancestor of these two
has yet to be found we know both rhinos
and horses
are distantly related to the same small
forest-dwelling predecessor called
hirachaethyrium
the genus lived during the eocene period
i've got more on them and
other tiny early mammals in another
video but today the hulking rhino and
majestic horse
have clearly gone in different
adaptational directions
despite this both species still belong
to the same larger category
the odd toad ungulates a classification
which also includes the taper
that's right there's a third branch in
this family tree
the taper is a squat somewhat odd
looking herbivore with a short trunk
like an elephant for grasping at food
despite also having little relation to
actual elephants
looking at these three side by side they
hardly look similar but that's the funny
thing about adaptation
up next we have seals and bears the
cuddly aquatic seal might appear far off
from the large terrestrial bear but
genetically speaking the two mammal
groups are pretty closely related
it's believed both animals share a
common ancestor in the pujilla
an extinct species of semi-aquatic
mammal over the course
of millions of years some members of
this ancestral species spent more and
more time in the water
and became the almost fully aquatic
group we now recognize as seals today
the other remained mostly on land and
became larger
heavier and more diverse into the
various modern bear species we're now
familiar with
but biologically speaking the two are
still cousins
continuing on we have the hippopotamus
and the dolphin
the four-limbed heavyset hippo and the
sleek flippered dolphin
might seem like total opposites at first
glance but like many of the other pairs
on this list
they share a common ancestor the two
groups split off around 60 million years
ago
in the group that eventually gave us the
dolphin the cetaceans
also includes all species of porpoises
and whales
meaning the whale and hippopotamus are
incredibly
also related what a curious lineage next
we have the elephant
which as we've already established isn't
as closely related to other african
megafauna like rhinos or hippos as you
might expect
so what are the closest living relatives
of the largest land animal on planet
earth
the rock hyrax a species of tiny
rodent-like mammals
and the manatee at the very least
manatees are a hefty leathery group of
animals
so you can somewhat see how such a
species might be related to the elephant
but the tiny furry rock hyrax seems like
quite the odd relative to the heaviest
thing on the african savannah
part of how we know the two species are
related is the makeup of the hyrax's
front teeth is actually similar to that
of an elephant's tusks
indeed the two species only diverged
around 65 million years ago
which isn't that impossibly long on an
evolutionary time scale
pretty interesting moving on we have the
echidna and the platypus
while these two don't look alike they
are perhaps the most made up seeming
organisms alive today
so it kind of tracks they'd be related
both groups are the only mammals
currently living which lay eggs
even stranger however the platypus is
able to detect electric fields with its
bill
and has venomous elbows like the
platypus the echidna can also detect
electric fields through its snout
which is part of what links the two
mammals to each other
what an incredible pair nearing the end
we have the giraffe and the pronghorn
antelope
giraffes are such unique mammals in
general with their extremely long necks
and characteristic spots
that you might not assume anything let
alone an antelope would be their
relatives
and indeed despite their name pronghorn
antelopes aren't actually antelopes at
all but an offshoot species more closely
linked to the giraffe
this relation is a relatively recent
scientific discovery
and frankly it's almost nice to know
that the truly unusual giraffes have a
genetic relative
they might still stick out as the
tallest living terrestrial animal but as
it turns out they are not alone
biologically speaking and at the end we
have jellyfish and coral
since jellyfish are free-floating
ethereal animals
and coral are so sedentary they hardly
seem like animals at all
you'd be forgiven for assuming they have
nothing in common
but in fact both jellyfish and coral are
cindarians
aquatic animals with specialized cells
for capturing prey
you might not think of coral as hunting
prey at all but in fact some species do
possess stinging tentacles like
jellyfish which they use to ensnare
floating zooplankton that gets too close
indeed some coral have even been
observed consuming
jellyfish which seems quite surprising i
wonder if they know their family
and that's the end of our analysis of
animals you might not have known were
related
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious
see you in the next video
you